[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes et à tous Bienvenue
c'est sens public 90 minutes de débats
de reportage et d'expertise sur Public
Sénat vous le savez la promesse et dans
le titre donné du sens à l'actualité
vous proposez des clés de compréhension
des crises que nous traversons et voici
le sommaire de ce 9 février c'est
l'image du jour le symbole du Ukraine
ancré en Europe son président ovationnés
par les députés à son arrivée au
Parlement à Bruxelles
[Applaudissements]
diplomatique qu'il l'aura vu passer par
Londres et Paris est réclamé
inlassablement des armes pour contrer
l'armée russe sentir le bilan de ses 48
heures historiques juste après ces
titres et puis dans notre second débat
c'est en Afrique que je vous emmène
après la République centrafricaine et le
Mali l'an dernier c'est le Burkina Faso
que les soldats français doivent quitter
avant la fin du mois ils sont poussés
dehors au profit des milices Wagner les
Russes sont-ils les seuls responsables
de ce sentiment anti-français qu'elles
ont été nos erreurs stratégiques réponse
dans trois quarts d'heure mais d'abord
ces mots du président et chef de guerre
Hélène ski nous nous défendons nous vous
défendons ce sont bien les valeurs de
nos démocraties qui sont attaquées
matthiasaraez
l'image est historique ligne ukrainien
retentit dans les murs du Parlement
européen
ski président d'un pays en guerre était
l'invité exceptionnelle du sommet des 27
à Bruxelles dans son plaidoyer pro
Europe le dirigeant ukrainien a rappelé
devant les parlementaires les enjeux
selon lui de la guerre mais nous nous
défendons contre la force la plus
anti-européenne du monde moderne nous
nous défendons nous les Ukrainiens sur
le champ de bataille nous vous défendons
napolé
cette tournée européenne le président
ukrainien a initié mercredi lors d'une
rencontre à Londres avec le Premier
ministre ritier sounac formation des
pilotes aide militaires les Britanniques
en ont profité pour annoncer un
renforcement de leur soutien dans la
foulée c'est à Paris que volodi
mirzelenski était reçu par Emmanuel
Macron accompagné pour l'occasion du
chancelier allemand Olaf scholls là
encore il réclame des armes pour se
défendre
plutôt l'Ukraine aura des armes
puissantes et à longue portée Emmanuel
plutôt nos pilotes aurons des avions
modernes Olaf plus forte sera notre
flotte de char je vous remercie d'avoir
commencé ce chemin plutôt l'agression
russe prendra fin
faire de promesses pour l'heure le
président français assure que l'Europe
sera aux côtés de l'Ukraine dans les
mois à venir le chancelier Scholtz me
rejoint ce soir et je n'en remercie
pour que nous puissions ensemble
d'exprimer notre solidarité notre
soutien notre volonté d'accompagner
l'Ukraine vers la victoire vers la paix
et vers l'Europe
à l'issue d'un dîner de travail à trois
Emmanuel Macron a décoré son homologue
ukrainien de la grand-croix de la Légion
d'Honneur une distinction que volodi
mirzky a souhaité dédié à son peuple
on analyse tous les symboles de cette
visite historique avec mes invités
Sylvie Berman bonsoir bienvenue ancienne
ambassadrice de France auteur de Madame
l'ambassadeur aux éditions tallendier
Patrick Martin Genier bonsoir bienvenue
à vous aussi spécialiste des questions
européennes et enseignants à Sciences Po
j'accueil Patricia les Monières bonsoir
Patricia bienvenue grand reporter
spécialiste des relations
internationales Mathilde Sirault
informatique
et puis en duplex 2 de Bruxelles Richard
Werly qui correspondant France Europe
pour le média Suisse Blic et je commence
avec vous Richard parce que vous avez
assisté à ce discours de de volozimir
Zelinski devant le devant le députés
européens à Bruxelles qu'est-ce qui vous
a frappé
écoutez ce qui était frappant c'est
d'abord l'émotion dans l'hémicycle alors
vous me direz qu'il avait déjà fait ça
au Congrès à Washington mais ici à
Bruxelles devant les députés européens
qui représentent les 450 millions
d'habitants de l'Union européenne
c'était très émouvant il a pris ses
postures de grands résistants au Fonds
européen de résistants pour l'Europe et
tout au long de son discours il n'a
cessé de remercier les Européens il a
encore fait ensuite lors de sa
conférence de presse avec Charles Michel
le président du conseil et Ursula
wanderlingen la présidente de la
commission c'est vraiment une posture de
résistant et de quelqu'un qui remercie
les Européens pour avoir été à ses côtés
c'est une manière aussi de leur dire et
il l'a dit restez à mes côtés vous
n'avez plus le choix maintenant et la
question qui va se poser c'est est-ce
que les européens peuvent tenir les
promesses faites car elles ont été
nombreuses aujourd'hui et on se rua ça
et on va détailler ça évidemment dans le
débat je reviens vers vous plus tard
Richard évidemment vous restez avec nous
pendant pendant tout ce débat Sylvie
Berman voir le président ukrainien
auventionné comme comme on l'a montré
dans les titres à son à son arrivée à
Bruxelles il y a effectivement ce
symbole qui est fort mais il faut le
relier à son précédent message qu'est-ce
qu'il avait dit au 27 la dernière fois
leur avait dit c'est peut-être la
dernière fois que vous me voyez la
dernière fois c'est le soir de la guerre
c'est le premier jour de la guerre et
effectivement il s'est adressé aux
Européens en disant c'est peut-être la
dernière fois que vous me voyez vivant
et c'est donc d'autant plus émouvant de
de le voir aujourd'hui non seulement
vivant mais à la tête d'un pays qui a
résisté de manière tout à fait
extraordinaire et ce et il se pose en
défenseur des valeurs de l'Europe c'est
aussi ça qui est intéressant dans c'est
pas nouveau mais là dans cette enceinte
c'est encore plus fort oui tout à fait
d'abord parce que bon bien évidemment il
souhaite une adhésion rapide à l'Union
européenne mais également je veux dire
dire aux Européens je me bats pour vous
c'est inciter les Européens à lui donner
les moyens de se battre même si bon en
premier lieu évidemment il se bat pour
défendre la souveraineté l'intégrité de
son pays mais c'est quelqu'un qui est
bon tout le monde dit c'est un grand
communicant c'est vrai qu'il est très
habile et que les discours qu'il tient
atteignent toujours leur cible il y a le
côté communicant il y a aussi du sens
politique Patrick Martin Genier il
commence cette tournée européenne ou ce
séjour parle la Grande-Bretagne c'est
pas hasard évidemment oui je dirais
qu'il a le sens de la hiérarchie
politique un peu la reconnaissance du
ventre c'est à dire qu'effectivement
très très clairement le chef de la
Coalition internationale ce sont les
États-Unis et donc premier voyage il
était tout à fait logique ce sang voyage
se fasse au Royaume-Uni qui est allié un
effectif des États-Unis et que lorsque
les États-Unis font un geste les
Royaume-Uni continue on l'a bien vu pour
les chars on a bien vu aussi que pour
les avions par exemple les États-Unis
avaient dit non pour l'instant donc les
les Anglaises ils ont également mais
c'est vrai il a le sens de la hiérarchie
politique c'est quelqu'un qui a une très
très grande finesse politique il sait
qu'il doit cette coalition
internationale en premier lieu aux
États-Unis et au Royaume-Uni parce que
même si on n'apprécie pas
particulièrement Boris Johnson il faut
quand même reconnaître qu'il ait été à
la pointe du combat pour la liberté en
Ukraine et la libération du crâne donc
ça c'est un point important une comme
l'a dit le Premier ministre ruchi-senac
une amitié inébranlable il a encore dit
aujourd'hui et donc effectivement c'est
cela et bien sûr après il y avait
Bruxelles mais je pense que Paris aurait
été fâché s'il n'avait pas fait cette
escale à Paris car comme ça ça paraît
tout à fait important mais en tout cas
oui il a le sens de la hiérarchie
politique Patricia lemonaire qu'est-ce
que vous retenez de ces 48 heures on est
là aussi pour faire le bilan de cette
séquence diplomatique
je pense qu'on est beaucoup dans le
symbole même si on dit qu'il le il
adresse des demandes aux Européens c'est
demande on les connaissait déjà donc là
on est dans un dans un passage très
symbolique parce qu'on est à la veille
du 24 donc dès un an on est sur le plan
purement militaire et technique vers une
tentative d'offensive offensive ou pas
offensive en tout cas la maman est dur
sur les 600 800 km de front où
s'affrontent russe et
ukrainiens donc il y avait une urgence
aussi parce que le moment est difficile
sur le terrain donc il fallait parce que
hésité à venir la demande lui avait été
faite il n'avait pas dit oui carrément
quand on la demande lui a été faite par
Charles Michel donc et puis là il s'est
décidé il s'est décidé
le secret c'est normal la sécurité
oblige
vous pouvez me peut-être me contredire
mais je pense que les informations que
j'avais été plutôt bonne et donc là il a
hésité mais le moment est important
aujourd'hui ce qui joue en Ukraine et
donc il faut absolument montrer aux
Européens qu'il les défend il l'a très
bien fait au Royaume-Uni quand il s'est
aussi à la Chambre réunir ce qui est
quand même pas souvent on peut le dire
il leur a rappelé que il sait faire
plaisir au peuple en quelque sorte il
leur a dit c'est vous qui vous êtes
dressez contre le nazisme vous êtes
l'unique nation à cette dressée en
premier pendant la guerre sous-entendu
les Russes vous vous aviez signé le
pacte avec
avec les nazis
donc
c'est vous donc merci à vous encore
d'être à mes côtés de ce de se battre
avec moi et donc on sent à quel point
c'est un communicant qui s'appuie sur
l'histoire et ce message effectivement
là encore bien il dit à l'Europe
défendez moi encore contre le méchant et
puis il y a évidemment la perspective ou
en tout cas l'espoir d'une intégration
rapide à l'Union européenne Richard
Verly je reviens vers vous parce que
dans l'article que vous signez pour Big
vous racontez cette anecdote que vous a
glissé un huissier à l'oreille à la à la
fin du discours du président ukrainien
oui c'était très frappant je me suis
approché il y avait un huissier donc qui
était là pour guider les personnalités
et quand je lui ai demandé alors vous
pensez quoi de l'Ukraine dans l'Union
européenne il m'a dit écoute dès que la
paix soit rétablie pour de bons il
seront dedans et je crois que c'est le
sentiment général Charles Michel tout à
l'heure lors de la conférence de presse
bien évidemment il n'a pas dit ça
textuellement mais il a reconnu que ça
allait très vite
Ursula wander Leon aussi ça veut dire
que les Ukrainiens promulgueux des lois
ils ont fait des arrestations pour des
raisons de corruption donc on voit bien
que le dossier Ukraine arrive très vite
il y aura un premier rapport au
printemps un deuxième à l'automne ça ne
veut bien sûr pas dire que l'Ukraine est
déjà dans l'Union européenne mais on
voit bien que l'échéance ne sera
sûrement pas celle d'une vingtaine
d'années comme on l'évoquait parfois
l'horizon 2028 2030 maintenant et
régulièrement cité à Bruxelles alors
c'est intéressant si vous nous dites
parce que c'est plutôt à contre-courant
de ce qu'on imaginait de ce qu'on a pu
dire d'ailleurs sur ce plateau Patrick
Martin Genier l'Ukraine 28e pays de
l'Union européenne à la fin du conflit
ou assez vite après la fin du conflit
alors ce serait une surprise et puis on
oublirait le calendrier on oublierait
les autres pays qui sont dans la liste
d'attente vous vous êtes sceptique ah
oui non on ne peut pas oublier un
calendrier écoutez quand j'écoute le
Premier ministre de Nice schmi à dire
que on doit entamer les négociations dès
maintenant et être dans l'Union
européenne en 2024 c'est tout à fait
irréaliste mais c'est aussi une volonté
politique très forte non non parce que
une volonté politique c'est une chose
mais franchement les obstacles les uns
derrière les autres il y a une plus
d'une quarantaine de chapitres qui
doivent être négociés avec l'unanimité
des chefs d'État du gouvernement qui
doit te dire oui ils doivent montrer
effectivement que sur toute une série de
sujets qui s'agissent de la lutte contre
la corruption ils ont commencé la
capacité de cette économie à faire face
à une économie concurrentielle le
respect de l'État de droit le respect
des minorités tout cela on sait que la
liste est longue explique le processus
est-ce que ça peut pas sauter par
volonté politique ah non parce que ce
serait faire sauter les traités et
toutes les règles d'adhésion et je
rappellerai enfin que les pays des
Balkans c'est plus
ils accepteraient pas de se faire
devancer par l'Ukraine même si on est
d'accord pour que le processus
s'accélère et que dans le gouvernement
ukrainien et bien en face tout et pour
respecter la feuille de route qui était
donnée à ce pays alors il y a plein de
thèmes à aborder je vais je vais avancer
dans ce débat à barman là la séquence
diplomatique de ces dernières 48 heures
bon elle elle a été on peut dire à la
fois surprenante et productive sur
l'étape parisienne Patrick Martin Genier
commençait à en parler tout à l'heure je
voudrais vous entendre là-dessus est-ce
qu'elle a été rajoutée à la dernière
minute qu'est-ce qu'on en sait de cette
étape parisienne alors moi je n'en sais
rien mais c'est probable parce que en
réalité il s'est rendu à Londres et cela
ça a été une surprise donc je pense que
le Président de la République a souhaité
le recevoir également et c'est la raison
pour laquelle il a invité la chose à la
dernière minute ce qui était très bien
d'ailleurs parce que compte tenu du
froid dans les relations
franco-allemande c'était important qu'il
voit ensemble le dîner avant de se
rendre au Conseil européen et puis comme
le dîner ski à voyagé dans l'avion du
président ça a été l'occasion aussi d'un
échange non-officiel et cela permet de
d'expliquer davantage ses positions de
poser les vraies questions donc ça je
pense que que c'est très important
d'ailleurs c'est Georgia Meloni qui
n'est pas contente il a réussi à le voir
à Bruxelles mais elle devait avoir en
tête le déplacement commun avec Mario
Draghi alors effectivement elle n'est
pas Mario Draghi donc elle a dû se
sentir un petit peu
Giorgia Meloni effectivement on a tous
en tête cette image dans le train c'est
ça où il y avait Mario Draghi la Schultz
et mal Macron aux côtés de du président
du chrétien Georgia mélodie tout de
suite
j'ai trouvé l'invitation de Paris à
zenenski hier plutôt inopportune parce
que je crois que la force que notre
force dans cette affaire c'est l'unité
les chaînes
et ce que je vois là ce sont des
questions de politique internes le fait
de favoriser sa propre opinion publique
intérieure risque de se faire au
détriment de la cause de l'Union et il
me semble que c'est ce qui s'est passé
un peu cavalier seul dans cette histoire
non parce qu'il y avait bon qu'est-ce
qu'on peut répondre à la on peut lire ça
à deux niveaux soit effectivement on lit
comme une volonté de réaffirmer ce
fameux coup locomotive tout ce que vous
voulez franco-allemande qui balbutie et
donc là justement de se servir de cet
événement pour réaffirmer que la France
et l'Allemagne semblait locomotive
autrement s'il faut inviter tous les
chefs de gouvernement et d'État qui sont
importants pourquoi pas l'espagnol
pourquoi pas le Danois etc alors en
revanche pour expliquer ce qui est
presque un acte de jalousie enfin de
mauvaise humeur de mélodie on voit qu'il
y a plusieurs gestes ou Paris mais de la
mets de côté regardez le ministre des
Affaires les deux ministres des Finances
se sont rendus à Washington en début de
semaine ils sont pas venus avec les
Italiens et les Italiens ont pourtant un
rôle important à jouer dans aussi bien
sur ce fameux pacte qui se qui se
négocie aujourd'hui au niveau européen
énergétique qui sont plutôt du côté de
la France aussi bien aussi dans le
soutien l'Ukraine les Italiens sont très
allant mais Mélanie est une voix elle
est très
pro la défense ukrainienne donc on a
besoin d'elle donc
excessivement difficile certains diront
effectivement
Emmanuel Macron a voulu montrer et bien
ce qu'il pense sur le fond de cette élu
droit et d'extrême droite donc il le
montre à sa façon d'autres diront il a
voulu privilégier le couple
franco-allemand et le réaffirmer dans un
moment difficile chacun fera sa lecture
Richard Berli est-ce que Georgia Meloni
exprime un sentiment qui était peut-être
partagé par d'autres leaders européens
ou pas d'ailleurs alors il y a une
spécificité italienne et ici à Bruxelles
on l'a très bien senti par exemple au
sein des journalistes italiens qui tous
se sont étonnés de cette présence
franco-allemande à Paris et du fait que
Georgia Meloni n'était pas invité il
faut quand même noter que l'un des
équipements l'un des derniers
équipements versés à l'Ukraine ce sont
les missiles franco-italiens solaires
Mamba qui sont vraiment quelque chose de
très important et donc Rome s'attendait
sans doute à être politiquement
récompensé pour cela donc peut-être y
a-t-il une forme de gaffe ou contraire
de vexation volontaire d'Emmanuel Macron
on sait que ces relations avec Georgia
Meloni ne sont pas très bonnes un mot
juste pour revenir en arrière parce que
vous aviez tout à fait raison tout à
l'heure d'insister sur le fait qu'il y a
7 chapitres et qu'il ne s'agit pas
d'ouvrir dès maintenant des négociations
avec l'Ukraine mais il faut quand même
avouer que quand vous êtes ici à
Bruxelles vous comprenez bien qu'il y a
une exception ukrainienne le cas de
l'Ukraine n'est pas traité comme le cas
des autres pays candidats et on peut
imaginer que plus la pression sera forte
surtout si une paix venait être rétablie
et bien c'est exception ukrainienne elle
va quand même peser en faveur d'un
calendrier plutôt accéléré Sylvie
varmann ça vous ferait réagir oui tout à
fait parce que le l'Union européenne est
fondée sur le droit et fondé sur des
traités et il y a un acquis
communautaire il y a des convergences
avec l'Union européenne dans tous les
domaines et tout à l'heure vous avez
évoqué justement le problème de la
corruption ils ont fait un effort parce
que le la Commission européenne et le
Conseil européen rendait à Kiev enfin on
se rend bien compte que c'est quand même
quatre gouverneurs de province que c'est
quelqu'un de l'administration
présidentielle le vice ministre de la
Défense que le ministre de la Défense a
plus ou moins essayé de couvrir et du
coup il a été un petit peu menacé à son
tour c'est la partie émergée de
l'iceberg ça veut dire que c'est un pays
qui était terriblement corrompu qui
était assez postes soviétique en ce sens
donc il y a beaucoup plus de travail à
faire que cela et puis il y a aussi la
justice qui n'a pas indépendante il y a
aussi les le système de d'oligarchie
donc c'est impossible qu'il puisse y
avoir la tonalité de Bruxelles que nous
que nous donnons exception
ukrainienne sont des mots qui
l'entendent dans les couloirs
qui est beaucoup plus politique il y a
un phénomène qui se produit en ce moment
à Bruxelles parce que la visite de
zoninski à Bruxelles a fuité parce que
il y a une sorte de concurrence malsaine
au sein des institutions européennes
entre Charles Michel le président du
Conseil européen ayant reçu la finale
qui ne s'apprécit guère du tout et donc
on a vu ces défilé assez sang à Kiev et
ça devenus ça devient indécent d'une
certaine façon et lorsque Charles Michel
a accueilli ce matin et la ski il lui a
dit bienvenue à la maison bienvenue dans
l'Union européenne voilà et donc alors
que la fin de la laine a été bien plus
prudente en disant il y a des étapes à
franchir nous ferons tout dans ce sens
donc on voit bien qu'il y a une sorte de
dysfonctionnement européen un mot rapide
là-dessus encore beaucoup de thèmes il
faut l'unanimité pour eux à chaque
chapitre alors avant que tout soit
d'accord sur pour donner leur vote à
l'Ukraine je pense qu'on va passer
quelques années
moi et années sans doute pour en
reparler ce qui est sûr c'est que cette
vis je reviens à la visite parisienne
l'étape parisienne de de volo dumer
Zelinski a permis un rapprochement vous
l’évoquez avec aussi ce ce trajet en
avion avec Emmanuel Macron va-t-il le
président
ukrainien affirme c'est dans une
interview chez nos confrère du Figaro ce
matin qu'Emmanuel Macron a changé je
crois qu'il a changé et qu'il a changé
pour de vrai cette fois oui Thomas le
président
ukrainien dit observer un vrai signal
dans l'attitude de son homologue
français il a changé pour de vrai cette
fois je crois que la confiance est
réelle aujourd'hui ce sont ces mots
signes que la méfiance était plutôt de
mise du côté de velody Myers qui ces
derniers temps puisque on l'a vu
Emmanuel Macron a rappelé qu'il l'avait
reçu à l'Élysée en 2019 il en a profité
pour lui remettre la Légion d'Honneur un
an jour pour jour auparavant il faut le
noter Emmanuel Macron était à Kiev après
s'être rendu d'abord à Moscou parce
qu'on se souvient durant les premiers
mois de la guerre le président français
a voulu se poser en médiateur entre
l'Ukraine et la Russie cherchant à
maintenir coûte que coûte un dialogue
avec Vladimir Poutine c'est stress cette
stratégie on peut le dire aujourd'hui et
plutôt mise en échec Emmanuel Macron a
compris qu'il ne parviendrait pas à
ramener Vladimir Poutine à la raison
d'ailleurs leur dernière conversation
remonte au mois de septembre c'était il
y a 5 mois la ligne de crête qui
consistait à expliquer qu'on pouvait
aider l'Ukraine à gagner mais sans faire
perdre la Russie était difficilement
tenable alors est-ce que pour vous la
cette rencontre à trois à Paris hier
soir marque un tournant alors sur le
fond le soutien à l'Ukraine depuis
février dernier ne fait que monter en
gamme jusqu'à la livraison dernièrement
de chars ce que Paris avait plutôt exclu
jusque là l'Élysée s'était engagée à ne
pas franchir la ligne rouge de la
cobelligérance en olivant que des armes
de défense la question désormais est
posée des avions de combat mais c'est
surtout sur le plan du discours et dans
la tonalité qui est manuel Macron semble
avoir changé alors on écoute justement
ce que le président français disait le 9
mai à Strasbourg
nous aurons à le faire avec autour de la
table et l'Ukraine et la Russie les
termes de la discussion et les
négociations seront fixées par l'Ukraine
et la Russie mais ça ne se fera ni dans
la négation ni dans l'exclusion de l'un
l'autre ni même dans l'humiliation
c'est cette théorie de l'humiliation de
la Russie et cette volonté auprès de
Moscou de lui garantir de l'essai de la
sécurité dans le règlement du conflit
qui avait été plutôt mal perçue du côté
de Kiev aujourd'hui à l'occasion de
cette visite qui a été organisée à la
dernière minute Emmanuel Macron semble
vouloir un minima lever certaines
ambiguïtés avec cette phrase qui montre
le glissement du président français la
Russie ne peut ni ne doit emporter la
guerre Sylvie Berman est-ce que merci
Mathilde est-ce que Emmanuel Macron a
renoncé à parler à Vladimir Poutine non
je ne crois pas je pense que c'est
inutile pour le moment parce que il est
Vladimir Poutine est déterminée est en
train de préparer une offensive et dont
je pense que ça ne servira à rien mais
il a dit qu'il ne renoncerait pas et que
il ne voulait pas laisser au seul
erdo one le rôle de médiateur nécessaire
enfin le moment venu encore encore une
fois ce n'est pas le moment c'est le
moment de la guerre c'est le moment de
d'avoir des gages sur sur le champ de
bataille c'est effectivement le
président turc qui joue ou qui tente de
jouer ce rôle de médiator aujourd'hui
Patricia Lemonnier oui il le tente avec
plus ou moins de succès j'ai envie de
dire il est certain que le président
Macron veut être à la table des
négociations le jour elle se passera ça
et donc il veut maintenir il veut
maintenir cette option très forte et là
je crois que le glissement auquel vous
avez fait allusion je crois que ce
glissement lui est imposé par les
circonstances c'est à dire ce n'est pas
lui qui en réfléchissant à l'Élysée à
diva finalement il faut que je j'évolue
ma position évolue je crois que le
terrain s'impose là le non retour de
Vladimir Poutine est-ce que Vladimir
Poutine veut le prendre au téléphone on
ne sait pas peut-être le Président il y
a peut-être eu des tentatives françaises
tout ça nous l'ignorons donc le
président russe pour l'instant et dans
une logique il y a assez cette logique
qui s'impose et c'est la guerre
malheureusement qui s'impose et donc
cela a imposé une inflexion de la
politique française le président
français fait preuve de pragmatisme en
quelque sorte mais c'était pas une
erreur de tenter de parler à la lumière
Poutine ah non absolument pas il faut
savoir que les canaux diplomatiques sont
toujours ouverts on a toujours parlé au
pouvoir très fort au dictateur et de
toute façon je pense que ces contacts
diplomatiques n'ont pas été inutiles
dans un premier temps et ensuite on sait
très bien qu'il a fallu avoir un canal
diplomatique pour l'évacuation des
échanges de prisonniers de part et
d'autre premièrement deuxièmement
rappelez-vous le danger autour de la
centrale nucléaire des aporidges quand
même le président de la République a
reçu à l'élyser donc Monsieur Raphaël
grossi le directeur de l'agence de
l'énergie internationale de l'énergie
atomique et donc tous ces contacts se me
semblent importants et naturellement
aujourd'hui le temps est à la guerre
c'est une course contre la montre mais
on sait très bien qu'au final il faudra
bien une table des négociations et je
pense que la France a un rôle à jouer ne
serait-ce que parce qu'elle est une
grande connaissance nucléaire membre
permanente du Conseil de sécurité et si
du Berman c'est pas parce qu'il y a pas
de coups de téléphone entre Vladimir
Poutine et Emmanuel Macron qui a pas
effectivement des canaux diplomatiques
qui continuent de fonctionner ou pas du
tout je vous vois très dubitative si les
grands patrons se parlent pas de toute
façon c'est c'est une guerre qui a été
décidée par Poutine et c'est le seul qui
en mesure de décider d'influer sur les
événements donc non je pense pas qu'il y
ait des canaux diplomatiques
les militaires oui mais ça a toujours
été dans des soucis
ça a toujours été dans des soucis de
déconflexions je veux dire pendant la
guerre en Syrie les Américains avaient
tous les jours au téléphone leurs
homologues russes à plusieurs niveaux
opératifs et au niveau du chef
d'état-major également et les Américains
continuent alors on va maintenant se
poser la question des armes quel armes
faut-il livrer à l'Ukraine puisque l'un
des objectifs évidemment de ce voyage de
merzialinski c'est d'obtenir toujours
plus d'armes on ouvre ce chapitre tout
de suite avec Tam traduis qui doit être
juste derrière le rideau bonsoir table
bienvenue pour nous rappeler cette
proposition de résolution pour apporter
son soutien à l'Ukraine adopter cette
semaine au Sénat et oui une proposition
de résolution qui vise à apporter son
soutien qui vise à condamner la guerre
d'agression menée par la Russie et qui
appelle aussi au renforcement de l'aide
fournie à l'Ukraine le texte dont
l'auteur et le président du groupe Les
Indépendants Claude malurey a fait
consensus au Sénat d'ailleurs il a été
largement cossigné par d'autres
présidents de groupe sauf sur un point
un point alinéa 31 précisément qui dit
que la proposition de résolution invite
le gouvernement en lien avec ses
partenaires européens à poursuivre et à
renforcer en particulier les livraisons
d'armes à l'Ukraine dans les domaines
identifiés comme les plus nécessaires
par les autorités ukrainiennes pour
Claude malurey c'est simple il faut
livrer à l'Ukraine toutes les armes
qu'elle demande pour non seulement
résister mais aussi chasser l'occup
écoutez il faut qu'il perde cette guerre
il faut donc augmenter notre soutien il
faut l'augmenter par des chars c'est
décider il faut l'augmenter par des
missiles à longue portée ce n'est pas
tout à fait décidé et c'est important il
faut l'aider et c'est bons sentiments
personnel en tout cas par des avions
mais on s'aperçoit que l'Europe n'a pas
d'avion que qu'on a que la France a
environ 200 avions dans évidemment elle
a besoin pour ce pour défendre son
propre territoire ou pour ses missions à
l'étranger voilà et Claude m'aurait
d'ailleurs d'appeler au réarmement de
l'Europe une position donc très
offensive qui n'a pas fait l'unanimité
dans l'hémicycle les communistes s'ils
sont opposés après les chars lourds
porteurs d'obus à uranium ou appauvri
des avions de chasse demain des missiles
et à chaque grand nouveau des soldats
formateurs de l'OTAN directement engagés
la résolution donne en fait le feu vert
aux franchissement futur de toutes les
lignes rouges et surtout elle fait
l'impasse sur tout appel à une
initiative de négociation et de paix ce
n'est pas un oubli c'est un choix celui
de la guerre comme seul chemin possible
oubliant la leçon de tous les conflits
récents on va tous les parlementaires ne
sont pas d'accord sur l'aide à apporter
à l'Ukraine il y a donc matière à
débattre tout simplement oui et
d'ailleurs à l'Assemblée nationale tous
les groupes de l'opposition on demandait
un débat au Parlement sur l'aide de la
France à l'Ukraine et plus
particulièrement sur la question des
armes pour le président de la commission
de la défense et des Affaires étrangères
au Sénat Christian Cambon il ne faut
d'ailleurs pas laisser la représentation
nationale de côté dans cette séquence
car on est selon lui dans un moment de
flottement de l'opinion regardez ce
qu'il dit il dit les gens voient cette
crise qui ne se terminent pas aucune
négociation ne se noie actuellement or
le Parlement reste une interface entre
l'opinion et le gouvernement des débats
il y en a eu chez nos voisins européens
en Allemagne en Suisse au Royaume-Uni
dans l'opinion et au Parlement il y a
même eu des examens de conscience sur
les relations passées avec la Russie en
France et bien les parlementaires
demandent aussi bien avoir les opinions
les avis les désaccords qui doivent
s'exprimer au Parlement sans quoi selon
eux le débat il va gagner les Français
le doute peut éventuellement s'installer
quand on bien fondé bien du soutien à
l'Ukraine dans cette guerre évidemment
les mots ont de l'importance le mot
guerre justement Emmanuel Macron refuse
de dire que nous sommes en guerre avec
la Russie c'est sa position depuis le
début la France n'est pas partie
prenante et ça malgré le soutien affiché
malgré l'envoi de chars de radar et
peut-être demain donc d'avion les Russes
eux ont dénoncé fin janvier je les cite
l'engagement direct des Occidentaux en
raison de l'envoi de nouveau charme et
du côté du quai d'Orsay on assure que
nous ne sommes pas en guerre contre la
Russie et pour Claude malure reste là
n'est hypocrisie
les dirigeants européens qui disent on
n'est pas en comédie gérance on n'est
pas en guerre j'espère qu'ils utilisent
uniquement pour des raisons tactiques et
pour ne pas mettre de l'huile sur le feu
mais j'espère que dans leur fort
intérieur ils savent parfaitement qu'on
est en guerre parce que ce sont eux qui
nous ont déclaré la guerre et ça fait
déjà pas mal d'années que la guerre que
la deuxième guerre froide et commence
merci Tom pour toutes ces informations
et notamment c'est cette déclaration de
Claude malurey Patrick Martin Genier la
France est-elle est-ce que c'est une
grosso modo il nous dit c'est hypocrite
de ne pas employer ce terme qu'est-ce
que vous en pensez non écoutez dire que
la France est en guerre ça voudrait dire
qu'on peut nous pourrions recevoir un
missile sur Paris donc je veux dire il
faut faire très attention à ce qu'on dit
qu'il y a une coalition internationale
que nous soyons intervenants pour aider
par tous les moyens nécessaires
possibles l'Ukraine oui bien sûr mais
nous sommes pas comme les gens à
supposer qu'il y ait une définition
juridique de la cobellence certains
militaires disent que ça n'existe pas
donc nous sommes là effectivement nous
soutenons l'U mais il y aura il y aurait
kobelligence si un soldat de 2 temps ou
un soldat français mettez les pieds en
Ukraine ce qui n'est pas le cas
aujourd'hui est-ce qu'il y a une
certaine hypocrisie moi je dirais pas
cela je dirais qu'il y a une certaine
prudence qui est nécessaire on l'a bien
vu partout parce que à partir du moment
où vous dites que vous êtes en guerre
directement contre la Russie ce sera un
prétexte pour le Kremlin pour un
feuilleté effectivement avoir des
actions récursoires en tout cas des
actions qui pourraient être dangereuses
on a vu qu'ils avaient évoqué le risque
nucléaire donc on ne peut pas encourir
ça car chaque chef d'État gouvernement
est là aussi pour protéger sa propre
population votre avis là dessus
c'est les mots un sens et nous ne sommes
pas en guerre nous ne sommes pas sur le
terrain et les les Soviétiques avaient
aidé les Vietnamiens dans la guerre
contre le
les États-Unis et pour autant il n'y a
pas eu une guerre entre les États-Unis
et l'Union soviétique à l'époque
alors on va parler maintenant des des
demandes d'armes de volodières Patricia
et on a un peu l'impression qu'il se
répète qui demande toujours la même
chose mais ça fonctionne quoi cette
opiniâtreté elle elle pèse elle pèse
peut-être sur les opinions
internationales et par ricochet sur les
gouvernements oui juste avant de
répondre à votre question je vais juste
dire que je trouve ça très irresponsable
de la part de Claude malloret de dire
qu'on est comédie irresponsable et c'est
dangereux bon fermons la parenthèse je
réponds oui après c'est le débat
parlementaire aussi néanmoins je trouve
que c'est très c'est très exposé la
France et c'est très exposé la France ou
critiques russes et on sait très bien
qu'avec la Russie il faut quand même pas
trop jouer sur les mots Dieu sait si eux
par contre ne se privent pas d'utiliser
des mots pour nous entraîner dans un
conflit de plus en plus fort alors sur
la stratégie Zelensky et et
cette espèce domino entre entre
l'opinion et les gouvernements qu'est-ce
que vous en pensez on a l'impression
effectivement que chaque fois il demande
plus et qu'il obtient il a obtenu les
chars en particulier et puis il y a les
ça c'est des demandes officielles c'est
les demandes qui sont ouverte et puis il
y a les autres demandes qui se font
derrière qui sont ce dont il a
réellement besoin là aujourd'hui pour se
battre contre les Russes parce qu'on
sait très bien que ces chars avant
qu'ils soient opérationnels il va
falloir quand même s'écouler un peu de
temps quelques semaines au mieux un mois
et encore pour les premiers en tout cas
donc alors les avions on en parle pas
même si même si pour les avions il y a
quelque chose qui nous a souvent tous
échappé les Américains avaient voté cet
été dans leur budget à un moment donné
enfin des crédits pour former des
pilotes on en parle pas ils ont voté les
crédits mais on parle pas de ce qui se
passe bon c'est comme les Anglais ils
votent des crédits ils disent on va pas
vous on va pas envoyer d'avion donc on
sent bien qu'il y a des choses qui se
préparent du côté des avions on se
prépare des raisons j'imagine
stratégiques à ne pas trop en dire
à ne pas trop s'étaler sur certaines
choses ce dont ont besoin terriblement
les Ukrainiens aujourd'hui c'est pas
tant des avions et des chars qui qui
sont finalement deux types d'armement
qui vont de pairs des avions protégeant
les chars etc mais c'est surtout des
munitions et ça ils n'en n'ont pas ils
n'en ont ils en ont de moins en moins en
tout cas et nous n'en avons pratiquement
plus même les Américains ont des
problèmes d'approvisionnement de
munitions les généraux américains qui
disent toujours prudence prudence mais
pourquoi ils disent prudence prudence
parce qu'ils voient leur stocks se vider
et ils ne veulent pas on est obligé de
demander ils ont été obligés de demander
aux Israéliens de vider les stocks
qu'ils avaient mis en dépouche chez eux
donc il y a un vrai problème de la
machine industrielle européenne sur le
plan des armements qui étaient
complètement
réduites à néant
le président Macron a eu beau dire on
est en état de guerre et il faut
relancer la machine en tout cas la
machine pour l'instant elle a rien à
lancer donc il va falloir fournir et
c'est ça le vrai problème aujourd'hui
des Ukrainiens l'instant où nous nous
parlons dans les jours qui viennent
c'est les munitions je vois Richard
Werly qui nous fait signe depuis
Bruxelles vous lit intervenir vous
écoute oui ce qui est très intéressant
c'est que l'Union européenne
nous avons besoin d'artillerie de
munitions de chars modernes de missiles
à longue portée d'avion de chasse
moderne merci de nous offrir le soutien
militaire que vous nous offrez merci
d'en faire davantage nous devons aller
plus vite que notre agresseur
Patrick Martin Genier cette phrase nous
devons aller plus vite que notre
agresseur comment vous l'analysez on a
plutôt l'impression que la situation est
un peu figée sur le terrain alors
peut-être que je me trompe et que
effectivement il y a une il y a des
soldats russes de une armée russe qui
commence à progresser de nouveau c'est
ça oui c'est ça la le problème c'est que
la présence fallait troupes sur place
sont en grosse difficulté les Ukrainiens
sont en très grande difficulté et vous
savez il y a une sauce l'institut
d'étude de la guerre a dit à Londres
qu'aujourd'hui l'offensive avait d'ores
et déjà commencé sur le terrain donc ils
sont en grande difficulté aujourd'hui il
y a une véritable course contre la
montre et donc ça veut dire que
le problème aujourd'hui c'est
l'acheminement le dé très cheminement et
je crois que les Britanniques l'ont bien
compris d'ailleurs parce que parmi les
chars qui vont livrer challenger et bien
c'est char qui devaient arriver d'ici
quelques mois devraient arriver d'ici le
mois de mars avril l'Allemagne également
a décidé de donner des chats nous sommes
non seulement léopards d'eux mais
léopard 1 qui vont arriver assez
rapidement il y a aujourd'hui une vraie
course contre la montre et il a raison
la volody merzenas qui aujourd'hui c'est
ça la clé du succès ou de l'échec c'est
l'acheminement rapide des armements non
seulement des chats mais aussi des armes
à longue portée des missiles solaires et
éventuellement le cas échéant des avions
donc c'est ça aujourd'hui ce dont a
besoin avant tout l'Ukraine alors on va
parler des charges justement et je vous
propose un témoignage c'est celui
d'un soldat ukrainien mitrailleur de la
première brigade de chat il est dans les
champs de la région du Dombas on est
donc à l'est de l'Ukraine et il est sur
un char soviétique assez rouillé écoutez
ce qui nous dit
je pense que le déroulement de la guerre
changera lorsque nous recevrons des
armes lourdes des véhicules blindés de
transport de troupes et des requêtes
longue distance
je n'ai jamais vu dans la vraie vie de
Charles Abraham et léopard je ne les ai
vu que sur Internet il est clair qu'il
faut nous apprendre à les utiliser je
pense que deux semaines suffisant
amplement pour apprendre à les faire
fonctionner l'essentiel est d'avoir
envie d'apprendre
bon c'est peut-être un peu optimiste
Patricia lemonnière je vous ne vous nous
parliez peut-être de formation qui sont
en cours sans que elles soient forcément
médiatisées c'est une c'est une
possibilité c'est une hypothèse pour
l'instant là les chars Abrahams
Américains ou les Léopards 2 parce qu'il
y a il y a deux générations de Charles
léopard aucun a été livré qu'est-ce
qu'on en sait de ça non pour l'instant
ceux qui risquent arriver en premier ça
devrait être les challengers
britanniques
suivi de près ou de loin je sais plus
par
j'essaie de comprendre moi les uns sont
disponibles c'est ça ou plus rapide
qui sont plus anciens qui sont beaucoup
plus anciens bien beaucoup plus anciens
qui sont stockés et donc a priori
pourrait être remis au point et livré
assez rapidement et qui serait assez
opérationnel également vous savez que
l'Allemagne est en train de revoir toute
son armée de moderniser sachant que au
début quand même il y avait des
interrogations sur
l'effectivité l'opérationnalité des
armées allemande parce que il y avait
des difficultés on a dit que pour les
chars léopard 2 l'entreprise qui les
fabriquait et oui de ne pouvait devait
d'abord les démonter les remonter et
donc c'était extrêmement lent donc là
c'est Charles léopard 1 pourrait être
envoyé entre 100 ou 150 ce qui ferait
quelques choses très important sachant
que les chats léopardeux il y en a je
crois à travers l'Europe environ 2500
donc de quoi a besoin du créneau
aujourd'hui environ minimum 300 à 350
chars donc ça c'est tout à fait faisable
il faut que ce soit fait rapidement
juste un petit aparté qui ont vraiment
une différence technologique avec les
nouveaux chats russes si on leur donne
des léopards 1 1 on n'aura pas de ils
auront pas de différence et c'est très
important la différence justement la
supériorité technologique s'ils veulent
marquer des points
des difficultés de logistiques mais
aussi de du manque de munitions des
Ukrainiens est-ce que vous pensez
qu'après une première phase de conflit
ou la Russie a plutôt été étonnée de la
robustesse des Ukrainiens on rentre dans
une nouvelle phase du conflit ou là à
contrario c'est la Russie qui est en
train de reprendre un petit peu des
forces et regagner du terrain Sylvie
verman là-dessus oui c'est la Russie qui
est à l'initiative grâce à cette
mobilisation de 300.000 300.000 hommes
et c'est reconnu à la fois par les
services américains mais également par
voeux diverselanski alors il le dit
parce que bien évidemment c'est de
nature à inciter les Européens à fournir
davantage d'armes et plus vite mais
c'est quand même une véritable
préoccupation des
Ukrainiens et effectivement la grande
force de la Russie malgré toutes les
erreurs logistiques qui ont été commises
et bien c'est le fait que c'est un
rouleau compresseur parce que ils sont
beaucoup plus nombreux vous parliez de
l'Allemagne je vous propose d'écouter un
dernier témoignage dans ce dans ce
premier débat en tout cas extrait de
discours on peut ce serait plus juste de
le dire comme ça celui du chancelier
Scholtz alors lui aussi c'est ce matin à
Bruxelles il évoque l'engagement
militaire humanitaire mais aussi et
surtout militaire de l'Allemagne côté
nous pouvons envoyer ce signal une fois
de plus et montrer que nous continuerons
à soutenir l'Ukraine dans la défense de
son indépendance et de son intégrité
aussi longtemps que nécessaire
l'Allemagne y apportera sa contribution
parmi les États de l'UE nous sommes
aujourd'hui le pays qui apporte le plus
de soutien financier sur le plan
humanitaire mais aussi le plus de
soutien concrets en termes de livraison
d'armes
Richard Werly est-ce que il y a une
sorte de concurrence entre pays
européens à être celui en termes de
finances ou d'armes et de celui qui
donne le plus alors une concurrence je
ne sais pas mais ce qui est sûr c'est
qu'il y a deux types d'aide il y a les
aides bilatérales d'un côté les aides
communautaire et effectivement plus
certains pays s'avancent plus les autres
vont suivre mais une chose qui est très
étonnante et très intéressante c'est
qu'au fond Vladimir Zelinski il y a tout
à fait compris que plus les demandes
d'armement vont être importantes plus
les armements en question
plus il va y avoir un engrenage sur le
terrain plus il lui faut le soutien de
l'opinion publique européenne et c'est
pour ça au fond c'était ça la motivation
de son discours ici à Bruxelles motiver
les opinions publiques européennes quand
ils leur dit nous vous défendons et bien
pour se défendre pour vous défendre les
Européens il faut les meilleurs armes
possible donc le lien politique est tout
à fait établi et il l'a bien compris
Patrick Martin Genier je vais vous
donner le le mot de la conclusion
peut-être pour parler de l'Allemagne
parce que quand même
ce discours enfin on s'habitue à tout
mais le un titre discours d'un
chancelier allemand il y a un an puisque
on était pas encore la guerre aurait
fait bondir tout le monde quoi c'est
complètement un changement de pied
majeur et qui a des conséquences aussi
sur l'engagement français d'une certaine
façon
cette coopération franco-allemande une
sorte de locomotive dans le soutien à
l'Ukraine ça veut dire aussi que
l'Allemagne a fait une révolution
copernicienne considérable avec son
passé et donc on peut dire aujourd'hui
que le chancelier Scholl s'a surmonté
ses propres difficultés intérieures
rappelez-vous que les verres étaient
vraiment à l'offensive il y avait une
frange pacifiste au sein du Parti
social-démocrate en réalité maintenant
tout cela est terminé la coalition est
solide derrière l'Ukraine et c'est
effectivement une évolution tout à fait
remarquable de la part de l'Allemagne
merci beaucoup merci à tous d'avoir
participé à ce débat ici en plateau et
depuis Bruxelles siberman je rappelle le
titre de votre livre madame
l'ambassadeur publier aux éditions
tallendier